موجه تسمم غازت مدارس الفتيات في ايران
صارت مخاوف من محاولات عقابيه خفيه صحيفه
الجاردينيا البريطانيه ربطت بين تسمم مئات
الطالبات في محافظه
نظام الايرانيه عقاب الفتيات على الحركه
الاحتجاجيه النسائيه منذ سبتمبر الماضي
بسلاح الارهاب البيولوجي نظريه تتوافق
معها تاكيدات للنشط الحقوقيه الايرانيه
المقيمه في نيويورك مسيح علي نيجات
قادت الدول الديمقراطيه الى ادانه هذه
السلسله من حالات التسمم وعزل نظام خامنئي
عبد الحميد اسماعيل زاهي زعيم اهل السنه
في زاهيدا وصف حوادث تسمم الطالبات بالعمل
غير الانساني تسمم الطالبات مناهض للاسلام
ومعادن لتعليم نساء وجاء انتقاما
لانتفاضتهن الاخيره
منذ بدء موجه تسمم الطالبات بحوادث متكرره
قرابه ثلاثه اشهر كان تصريحات المسؤولين
متناقضه بدات بالنفي وانتهت بالتاكيد
المقتضب بعد تسميم العديد من الطلاب في
مدينه قم تبين ان بعض الناس يريدون اغلاق
جميع المدارس خاصه مدارس البنات رغم تاكيد
نائب وزير الصحه الايراني حدوث حالات تسمم
للطالبات اصر على نفي تسممهن بمواد
كيميائيه
فما وزير الصحه فيقول ان سمن خفيا ادى الى
تسمم طالبات المدارس فيما المتحدث باسم
الصحه الايرانيه يقول ان تسمم ليس نتيجه
فايروس لكنه لم يتطرق لمزيد من التفاصيل
ومع التخبط السلطات الايرانيه بشان حقيقه
ما حدث للطالبات هناك بالمقابل اتهامات من
طرلمانيين لجهات خارجيه بالضلوع في تلك
الحوادث في خضم لجوء اولياء امور الى سحب
بناتهم من الفصول الدراسيه خوفا عليهن ما
ادى الى اغلاق بعض المدارس في قم في
الاونه الاخيره